hi this is presh talwalkar
consider two trains that are 100
kilometers apart
if each train moves at 50 kilometers per
hour how quickly will the two trains
meet
one way to solve this problem is by
considering the combined velocities of
the two trains
we can add up 50 plus 50 to get 100
kilometers per hour
we can then calculate the time it takes
them to meet by dividing the total
distance they travel by their combined
velocity
this gives us a result of one hour
now consider a trickier variation
imagine each train is moving at 75
percent the speed of light so they're
going very very quickly
how quickly will the two trains meet
one way to solve this problem is we'll
try adding up the velocities
we'll say that the two velocities
together will be 75 plus 75 percent
which equals 150 percent the speed of
light
so if you were an observer on the left
train you would actually see the
observer on the right train moving at 50
percent faster than the speed of light
and that's something really bizarre
because we know that no object is going
to move faster than the speed of light
so what's going on here
it's actually something very tricky
and it goes to the question of how are
we measuring time and speed
so imagine a train on the left is moving
with velocity u and a train on the right
is moving with velocity v
our question is if you're an observer on
the left train how quickly are you going
to perceive
the right train to be moving towards you
to solve this problem
we want to use this special relativity
velocity addition formula for collinear
movement
this states the observer on the left
train will view the right train as
moving at the speed of u plus v
divided by 1 plus u times v over c
squared
the factor in the denominator is going
to give us a correction
to make sure that nothing travels faster
than the speed of light
now you don't need to always use this
formula
if your trains are moving i'd say 50
kilometers per hour you can actually
just add up u plus v
the reason is that if the speeds you're
dealing with are much slower than the
speed of light
the denominator will actually become
approximately one because the two speeds
are very
slow compared to the speed of light
so this formula will actually reduce to
just adding up the two velocities u plus
v
so that's why when we had 50 kilometers
per hour you could actually just add up
the two velocities however when the two
speeds are much faster like 75 percent
the speed of light you want to make sure
that the two velocities don't add up to
faster than the speed of light
so we can substitute in 75 percent the
speed of light and we'll see that an
observer on the left train will see the
right train moving towards them at 0.96
the speed of light
so things get very tricky when you get
closer to the speed of light and special
relativity deals with this and part of
the reason it happens is because time
actually changes so in the rest of the
video i'm going to give you some
intuition about special relativity and
try and give you some sense of where
this formula is coming from
so we'll start out with the thought
experiment a light clock is something
that consists of a mirror at the top and
then bottom mirror which is also a
sensor
the distance between the mirrors will be
a length l
from the bottom mirror we're going to
shine a beam of light and it's going to
bounce off the top mirror and it's going
to come back and hit the sensor and
that's going to be one tick of the clock
so each time the light goes up and then
comes down that's one tick of the clock
we go up and down that's one tick of the
clock and again this is one tick of the
clock
so the first question is how frequently
is this clock going to tick
we can calculate this
by considering the distance the light
travels and dividing by the speed of
light
the light is traveling back and forth so
one tick distance will be two times the
length between the mirrors and then we
divide by the speed of light
so we calculate the time of one tick
will be two times the length divided by
the speed of light
now let's make things interesting
now let's put this light clock in motion
we're going to be stationary and
observing someone that's moving with
this light clock at velocity v so you
can imagine that we're an observer
outside and someone is on a train that's
moving with velocity v and we're
observing how we perceive their light
clock to be working
so the person who's on the train is
actually going to have this light clock
moving very normally the light is just
going to bounce off the centers of the
mirrors and operate very normally
but we outside the train are actually
going to see this light is moving in an
apparent path that's an upside down v so
let me show you what i'm talking about
when the light clock is in motion this
is the path of light we're going to see
the light is actually bouncing off the
mirror and it actually looks like it's
going in a v it's bouncing and then
bouncing down
so we actually see that the light is
traveling a longer distance than just
going back and forth
so this is going to change the
perception of time
so let's look at the geometry of the
situation
for one tick of the clock
we want to measure what's our perception
of the time that it takes for this light
to bounce off the mirror and come back
so the light is bouncing off in an
apparent upside down v shape and we want
to calculate the distance that that
light is traveling
we can calculate the tick of the clock
by calculating the distance the light
travels divided by the speed of light
now an important assumption here is that
we're going to assume the speed of light
is going to be the same in all frames
reference so even though that person is
on a train moving at velocity v that
light is still going to move at the same
speed of light
so what's the distance the light travels
well first we're going to calculate the
base of this triangle we know that the
train is moving for one tick delta t
prime and it moves at a velocity v so
the entire base will be v times delta t
prime
so each of these legs will be one half
of v times delta t prime
the distance between the two mirrors is
l and now we can calculate the
hypotenuse of one of the triangles
because this is a right triangle by
using the pythagorean theorem so the
hypotenuse will be the square root of
the sum of the squares of the legs and
that will be the same for both of the
hypotenuses
so we now have the total distance
traveled by the light apparent to us and
we can divide that by the speed of light
to measure our perception of one tick of
this clock we can simplify the formula
by solving for delta t prime and we'll
get the delta t prime equals two l over
c divided by the square root of one
minus v squared over c squared
two l times c if you recall was our
formula for delta t
so we've actually created a relationship
between one tick of the clock in motion
and one to the clock that was stationary
in other words
one tick of the clock that's in motion
at velocity v will equal one tick of the
clock that's stationary divided by this
correction factor
we can say that one over the square root
of one minus v squared over c squared is
this
uh variable gamma so we'll say that
delta t prime equals gamma times delta t
now gamma if v if the velocity is equal
to zero gamma is going to equal one that
means the two ticks of the clock will be
the same if the velocity is zero however
velocity gets to be more than zero then
gamma will be greater than one
so we actually have found
that the time when you're moving at
velocity v
is different than the time when you're
stationary you multiply it by this
variable gamma which is also known as
the lorentz factor
and what we've deduced here is a
phenomenon known as time dilation
we will perceive a clock that's in
motion
as moving slower the one tick takes
longer it looks like the clock is
actually running slow
what this means is that time is actually
moving slower as you go faster it's not
a mechanical error that the clock has
some problem with it it actually is the
case that the tick of this light clock
is going to be slo is going to take
longer
and this is not just a theoretical
phenomenon in our thought experiment
this is actually something that gps has
to take into account for in their clocks
as well as other effects of relativity
if they didn't do this they would
actually be off by several kilometers
every day
so now in order to get
to the formula for
the addition of velocities we're going
to have to go over one more concept this
is what happens when you have a moving
frame
and you want to change your coordinates
so imagine we have a frame of reference
we have some coordinates here and all
we're going to care about is just the x
coordinate
what we're going to do is imagine this
coordinate system is going to be put on
a train that's moving at velocity v so
when you're on the train you only care
about things relative to the train you
might care about seats that are in the
front of the train or the back of the
train you're not worried that the train
is moving under a velocity v so you have
a different coordinate system that
someone who's outside the train is going
to say hey that train is also moving
away i don't just care about the front
and the back of the train i also care
about where the train is relative to me
so if this train is moving you could
have a new set of coordinate system x
prime that's going to be just relative
to the
to the velocity of the train this
uniform velocity v
and we want to know how can you change
between coordinates of someone who's in
the train and just comparing coordinates
locally inside the train versus someone
who's outside the train saying hey i
know you ever local coordinates but i
also want to compare the velocity that
you're moving
so the classical way to do this is the
galilean transformation
you can get your old coordinate systems
as equaling the local coordinate systems
x prime plus v times t prime
the other transformation is the time is
going to be equal to t prime
what these two together are saying is
that velocities will add up together and
the time is absolute
if you wanted to change coordinates in
the other direction you would calculate
for the inverse operations
now we know that these things are not
true
if you had velocities that would add you
would actually have speeds that go above
the speed of light and we also know that
time is not absolute because we just
showed with the time clock the time
dilation is a concept so we need to
correct for these change of coordinates
in a different way for special
relativity
it's known as the lorentz transformation
we'll hypothesize that these coordinate
transformations will look very similar
to what we just had except we have this
factor k that's going to be some
adjustment for time dilation and other
things in special relativity
the inverse transformation we're going
to assume is going to look very similar
so can we figure out what k is if we
assume these are the change of
coordinates
well let's do a thought experiment
let's imagine we have two frames of
references that start at the origin
at the same time zero and we're gonna
shine a beam of light that's starting at
time zero
so let's try and keep track of this beam
of light
in our old coordinate system our our x
value is going to equal the speed of
light times the time we travel
similarly in our new coordinate system
it's also going to be the speed of light
times our time that we keep in this
coordinate system t prime
so we can substitute these values into
our assumed values for the lorentz
transformation and we get the following
equations which we can slightly simplify
now we have two equations and we can
actually solve for k
by eliminating c and t prime
we end up with the result that k is
equal to gamma or one divided by the
square root of one minus v squared over
c squared so this lorentz factor that we
saw in time dilation actually comes out
in these
in this lorenz transformation that we're
going to use for a change of coordinates
so we end up with the result that these
are the change of coordinate systems
when we're using the lorentz
transformation and there's a similar
transformation for time which i'm not
going to derive in this video
but it also involves this lorenz factor
so if we assume these
uh are the lorentz transformation we can
now come to our velocity addition
formula
so let's imagine
that an object moves at a
rel at a perceived speed of u prime in a
frame that's moving at a speed of v
so one way to interpret this is let's
imagine you're on a train moving at a
speed of v
and you are on that train and you are
moving at some speed you're walking
forward at a speed relative to the train
u prime
how are you going to add up u prime and
v
how is someone on the outside going to
see your speed because you're walking
and the train is also moving
so that's the question we want to answer
so what is the speed of the observer to
someone in a stationary frame how can we
add up u prime and v prime and v
so in our notation of the coordinate
transformations we have that u prime is
equal to d x prime over d t prime that's
our speed in our local coordinate system
and what we want is we want this the
speed
in the old coordinate system which will
be dx over dt
we can derive this by taking
differentials and dividing from our
lorentz transformation
so we'll take the differential of our x
transformation we'll take the
differential over t transformation
now we'll take the quotient of these two
and now we'll divide by dt prime
now we have dx prime over dt prime
in the numerator and denominator which
we can substitute which equals u prime
so the result we end up with
is that dx over dt is equal to u prime
plus v divided by 1 plus v times u prime
over c squared
and this is exactly the velocity
addition formula i presented at the
beginning of the video
in order to add up the two velocities we
add up the velocities but then we have
this correction factor to make sure that
the two velocities don't add up faster
than the speed of light
so special relativity is some very
interesting implications for how we can
observe time and how we observe speed
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books through
links in the video description